that anyone in the Kingdom would want to
buy them I don't know I hope so if there
are investors and the numbers add up and
it makes a good business then then the
private private sector could come in and
or companies could come in from the
kingdom I know that the pif is you know
they own Newcastle they have plans for
Newcastle for the future not just to
develop the football team but also to
develop the whole ecosystem within the
the the club
um but you know we will benefit Sports
in Saudi will benefit from these
collaborations and these ownership
because we do exchange programs already
with with Newcastle and with our
connections around the world
um and and you know the Premier League
is is the best league in the world
everyone's watching the Premier League
it's the best it's the most watched
vegan and Saudi and and uh and I think
in the region so um and you know there
are die-hard Die Hard fans of these
teams in the Kingdom so it would be a
benefit for everyone I think would
Manchester United be more desirable for
a Saudi to own it they have more fans
I really don't have the numbers but
Liverpool has been you know they've I
think increased in the past couple of
years their performance have been really
outstanding and and and I think they've
increased their fan base in in the
Kingdom especially with the performance
of Manchester as well so um I think they
both have a big fan base in the Kingdom
would you personally want to obviously a
takeover of a club
um I'm not in charge of that and and it
wouldn't really uh uh fall into our as a
Ministry of sports because we're in
charge of sports within the kingdom
um I think it's a difficult job to have
I think it's one of the toughest jobs to
have you know because you'll be in the
in the best league in the world fans
from all over the world uh and and and
to deliver a a performance that the fans
would accept I would say is very
difficult as we've seen in in a lot of
sporting events and and clubs and so on
um but you know an opportunity like that
I think anyone would love to be part of
because you know you go into such a club
with such a a history and Heritage and
and and and success uh I think it will
be difficult for anyone but I think it's
it's something that anyone would love to
be part of since the announcement by the
glaze is that they could sell Manchester
United have you had people approaching
you within Saudi saying we're looking at
a takeover maybe can you help us connect
with the glazes no honestly no just read
it on the news but no one has has
reached out to us yeah but you would
like to see someone from Saudi Arabia by
Manchester United yeah but you know for
the good reasons I would say uh you know
I wouldn't want some you know a company
or someone to buy the team and then they
they fail and and developing the team or
or or putting a plan for the future and
and and so on so it depends on the
circumstance and and and what will the
outcome become so I mean we've seen a
really strong and success uh phase with
Newcastle they were about to be
relegated and when paf came in their
performance got better uh they're
bringing the right people on board and
and we see them today third in the
league and I hope they continue uh to to
to strive for that so that's created a
lot of excitement in the Premier League
in Newcastle in England but also for us
in Saudi
but it concerns you at all the way some
other Premier League clubs have targeted
Newcastle for instance trying to limit
how many Saudi sponsors they can get
no I know with these leagues everyone's
looking for their own interest uh and
and there are rules and regulations uh
and and I think the Premier League will
always look at what benefits the Premier
League and and what benefits the the
competition and benefits everyone
um so you know ux you you understand
their position and you work for what's
best for you as well so I think it's
it's it's normal this is a big week for
football Cristiano Ronaldo is a free
agent
do you want Cristiano Ronaldo to play in
the Saudi League who wouldn't want him
to play in their league uh you know he's
a role model to a lot of uh young
players him and Messi uh today and and
uh you know you know I heard about these
speculations in the news as uh as
everyone else
um I don't have any details about about
any any of of uh of the reports that
have been coming out but you know what I
can say is that you know we have Messi
as a as an ambassador for for tourism in
in the Kingdom with the ministry of
Tourism and that benefited a lot uh in
in terms of Tourism for for the kingdom
if they can I'd love to see them both
play in the Saudi league and and you
know top players coming to the Saudi
league and play because that will you
know reinforce the programs that we're
doing it will showcase that you know the
league is stronger to Showcase that
there's
um potential for for the Youth to to
admire for the future and to be part of
that and that will drive more of the
youth to come into that what could you
say to Cristiano Ronaldo to convince him
to play in Saudi Arabia if that's what
you well I can't you know come into his
brain and know what he would want but I
can say that we have a strong League uh
it's not a it's one of the strongest in
in Asia
um you know we're we're building towards
a better future uh and and we see how
how the future holds up for that would
you say you're a strongly excited MLS
for interplay I don't know I don't have
the facts but uh to be honest but I
think you know when you look at our club
performance uh we've won the the AFC uh
and Club tournaments uh uh twice in the
past four years our national teams have
all of our national teams from the youth
until the the the the top team have
qualified to the Asian cup we won the
under-23 Asian uh Championship a couple
of months ago so
you know we're we are a strong Nation uh
in football and and people are crazy
about football I can say that he has a
lot of fans in the Kingdom so uh he
won't feel like he's he's uh he's not at
home I would say
um would you hope actually you could get
Messi to join as well Messi would join
the Saudi League you could have
Cristiano Ronaldo and Lionel Messi
playing together maybe for the only time
in their careers I would hope for the
top 100 players to join the the uh the
uh the league in in Saudi uh and and you
know uh for for for Saudi to have a
strong league and to have these players
come and play in in the league will not
just benefit Saudi Arabia it'll benefit
all the whole of Asia
um so it's a benefit for everyone is it
complicated to bid with Rhys and Egypt
or will you do it alone will it just be
Saudi If you bid for the 2031 I think if
you look at you know the next World Cup
will be in Canada uh the US and and
Mexico and I think the traveling between
them is actually longer than the
traveling between Saudi and and and
Greece and and uh and Egypt but uh you
know I think you know we've learned a
lot from hosting a lot of events in the
past we're preparing as I said for these
competitions that we have uh coming
hopefully and and I think you know Saudi
will be ready to host any uh
International or or big competitions or
or championships in the future we've not
seen Newcastle spend a lot of signs or
Superstars is this intentional to not
look lavish perhaps like some other
states own clubs but immediately just
throwing cash out there well the pif is
is business driven and they look at
numbers and they look at what needs to
be done and so on and I think they've
done the right job by coming in and
bringing the right people to come in and
to put a strategy for the future we
don't you know with everything that
we're doing we don't look at one year or
two year you know hype or or or or or or
you know glamor to do that we look at
the future and we look at a long-term
partnership or or a long-term deal that
we we can we can learn for the future
and we can develop that as as we go on
would
the purchase for another primary club by
the Saudi investors need to be very
clearly separated from the government
given that that pif is controlled by the
Saudi government I think that falls to
the regulations of the Premier League I
can't talk about that I think yeah that
depends on what the regulations are and
I'm sure that the pif will always abide
by the regulations of anywhere they go
to but it is a government entity
yeah it's not it's an it's a it's a
private entity but it's chaired by the
conference and and and but it's not it's
not a government entity
What's the progress you think you need
to make to host these events well there
are regulations that you need to and
requirements from from the ifs that you
need to abide by and and you know we we
accept a different point of views about
uh uh and and and and cultures around
the world uh you know what we what we
think is that we need to respect that we
do respect that but we also ask the the
you know everyone else to also respect
our values and our culture and and so on
you know we do the same when we come and
visit any tournament around the world uh
we don't we don't question the the
regulations there
um and we expect the same from them do
lots of Qatar and say well actually
these the improvements we need to make
to work arise to labor conditions I'm
sure they've done a lot uh from where
from where they are and I'm sure it's
not as bad as as what you know some
speculations are or some criticism is
coming out uh but you know and I'm sure
they're going to develop out of this and
and work you know towards the future
we're all developing countries in this
in this region how long did it take
Europe open and and the us or the West
to to reach to this level and that takes
time and that takes acceptance of
different
changes that you need to do what new
rights do you think there might be
inside or even say five ten years time I
don't know I can't speak about it now
but we take seriously all of these
issues and we listen and we we analyze
and we check what are the the steps that
we need to take in if it's the right
time to do any changes we do them uh if
we need more time to do that we do them
but the question about how free you can
be in Saudi Arabia some al-shabab a
woman was jailed over her tweets I have
no details about the case that she has
to be honest uh and and you know I've
seen more harsh uh tweets from from
Saudis against me personally and they
haven't been jailed so uh I don't know
what the situation is with her exactly
because I don't have detailed details
about the the case uh but you know
everyone's welcome there are rules and
regulations that that that abide
everyone and everywhere in the world and
we only ask people to abide by them and
respect them certainly more recently we
saw the America celebrating your win the
other day with a Saudi flag yeah scenes
unimaginable two years ago does this
sort of say you're all friends now
diplomatic relation to fully restored
between Saudi Arabia and cancer the
relationship in the region and the the
connection between all the countries in
the region is much deeper than
everything that that I think the the
Western media has been talking about we
do have our differences we do have our
our issues but that does not mean that
we we hate each other that means that we
need to sit together we need to discuss
things the Crown Prince in the opening
ceremony had the scarf of bataran
supporting in the opening ceremony we've
been working with the with our
colleagues and and Qatar in the past
months to make sure that you know we we
support them in in anything that they
need with the direction from the Crown
Prince to make sure that the World Cup
is a success
and and we stand by one another we do
have a different is yes like anywhere in
the world and and even brothers and in
one house have their issues and they
fight with each other but that does not
mean that we don't look at the future
and we don't look at the prosperity of
our people and what benefits the people
in the in the in in the region when you
talk about the progress we made
can women ever hope for equal rights
with men in Saudi Arabia well it depends
on what you mean by equal rights uh and
and I think women have a lot of Rights
in Saudi and and and and you know if
this is a social issue that that needs
to be sold it will be solved within
Saudi Arabia and within the people of
Saudi Arabia equal rights is having the
same rights well again do women have the
equal rights in the West
uh in terms of uh you know uh their job
salaries and and so on uh do they you
know there's legislation that actually
should ensure they do have equality
maybe in some countries and some
countries different uh and and again if
if this is an issue for the countries
this is an issue for the people in the
country I don't think you would accept
it if I come and tell you you need to do
one two three or else uh or else you
know we won't deal with you uh I think
you should respect what what we have
here spectacular culture you respect uh
you know and I think that you know a lot
of changes have been happening in the
Kingdom especially in empowering women
in the workforce and the kingdom and in
terms of sports you know in 2017 we had
zero national teams today we have 25
national teams that's our pride uh that
are proud of of uh representing the flag
and and representing the country so
there are changes that are happening
that that you know that are going to be
um hopefully developed to a better
future future for women and men in the
Kingdom but that's an issue for the
kingdom to to work on